hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute ein super tolles
rezept machen die samira freut sich auch
schon richtig drauf denn heute gibt
million cupcakes und weil die minions
esse gerne bananen essen gibt auch einen
leckeren bananen vertrag mit das so die
zutaten habe ich jetzt so hingestellt
und später werde ich die dekoration aus
modelle schokolade und von bau machen
und zeigt jetzt einfach mal ganz schnell
die zutaten sprach 125 gramm weiche
butter 125 gramm zucker bei aldi sind
schon zimmer waren etwas vanille extrakt
und salz 350 gramm mehl 25 gramm
kakaopulver sprach backpulver und natron
den halben teelöffel zimt und eventuell
etwas minze und du kleiner mann darf ich
mit zu gucken dann stelle ich jetzt hin
übrigens habe ich schon meine muffin
form vorbereitet und zwar habe ich hier
muffin förmchen in blau genommen weil
die halt so cool passen denn die haben
ja auch blauen hosen an fast alles heute
zuerst kommt jetzt die reiche butter in
die rührschüssel
da kommt er zu mir dazu dass man den
extrakt und auch etwas als und dann wird
das jetzt erst mal schön cremig gerührt
und wenn die butter zucker mischung weiß
cremig es gebe ich noch nach und nach
die eier mit das 1 1 nach dem anderen
da kann ich die zwischenzeit schon
minuten und die bananen verdrücken
jetzt gebe ich dass bananen muss noch
mit zu der ipod hammer show
als nächstes vermische ich ziehe die
trockenen zutaten unserer mädels dann
halben teelöffel sind dann braucht ihr
etwas natron falls ihr das nicht hab ich
echt schlimm dann im da einfach stolz
nato neben nochmal puderbach mein
vermieter natron inhalten teelöffel und
einen teelöffel backpulver so
eineinviertel arztkittel gehäuft und
dann noch kakaopulver mit atomwaffen
und dann direkt zur butter mischung mit
jetzt noch einmal ganz kurz verrühren
und eventuell brauche ich jetzt ein
bisschen will
aber traurig jahren schlüpft ein
jetzt müssen wir den teig nur noch
portionieren das mache ich jetzt mit so
einem ice portionierer geht am
einfachsten aber wir können auch einen
ganz normalen löffel benutzen so bei mir
werden sie jetzt auch etwas mehr als
zwölf machen
jetzt werden die muffins im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 175 grad für ungefähr 20
minuten gebacken als du mich hier raus
die muffins eine zier und kühlen bereits
ab ich habs jetzt hier mit einem tuch
abgedeckt damit sie nicht austrocknen
und ich brauche jetzt noch eine leckere
creme und mache jetzt mit promis creme
und zwar vor ich dafür 200 kommen freuen
milchschokolade und 100 gramm sahne und
die vollmilch schokolade habe ich schon
mal klein gestückelt damit schneller
geht und gäbe es die sahne hier in den
topf
lasst sie kurz aufkochen
und sobald sie kocht nehme ich sie
wieder runter und für die schokolade mit
dazu das rühre ich jetzt gleich so lange
bis sich die schokolade eben komplett
aufgelöst hat
los
und jetzt fühle ich diese schoko
mischung in ein größeres gefäß text ab
und stellt jetzt noch mal kühl bis ich
die creme daneben brauche und dann
können wir gleich die cupcakes oder die
muffins eben dekorieren die macht wind
und die schokoladen ghanas sind jetzt
beide schön kalt und ich werde jetzt
erstmal die muffins mit der gage
einstreichen
damit ich sie gleich mit modelle
schokolade verzehren kann es nämlich
einfach so ein bisschen kanal auf so
einem winkel palette streicht es los auf
kanal ist diese shopper krieg
die machen das ist ein gestrichen und
die sitzen jetzt hier auf so einem kühl
pads damit sie schneller kalt werden und
ich werde jetzt schon mal die deko
vorbereiten für die deko benutze ich
etwas modelle schokolade habe ich hier
in weiß und die färbe ich jetzt ein mit
lebensmittelfarbe passte in geld und das
mache ich jetzt eben mal schnell und
dann brauche ich außerdem noch ein
bisschen schwarzen modell schokolade
ich brauche ein paar als stecher dann
nehme ich mir einfach so ein paar ja das
sind so vom spritzbeutel die töne und
einfach noch ein paar andere sachen
jetzt kenne ich das erstmal bisschen
durch und dann gehe ich gleich ein paar
tropfen damit dazu
do
habt ihr dieses schöne geld und jetzt
nehme ich mir schon ein kleines stück
weg vor das aus wenn es zu arg lebt
einfach dass der bäcker stärke benutzen
die konsistenz von der modelle
schokolade ist jetzt ziemlich weich also
was ist hier ziemlich warm ist und ich
hab ja auch die farbe ein geknetet
das auch helfen und jetzt habe ich hier
so einen ausstecher eigentlich ist es so
ein dessert ring und er ist etwas
kleiner als der film aber das macht
jetzt nichts denn ich schlecht es jetzt
erstmal damit aus
dann freue mich dass es mit den fingern
so ein bisschen vor
jetzt setzt sich das hier somit ich
drauf und drückt mit den fingern jetzt
hier am rand rund
jetzt können wir hier mit seinem
werkzeug dass es so einen kletter und
fondant blätter könnte das so schön nach
unten stehen
ich habe jetzt die oberfläche ein
bisschen antrocknen lassen und jetzt
werde ich die einzelnen minions
dekorieren hier habe ich jetzt schon mal
einen vorbereitet also ich mache es
welche mit einem auge und welche mit
zwei augen der einäugige könig
weil der stewart zum beispiel hat ja
auch noch ein auge und daher zwei augen
und er hat zwei um verschiedene farben
und deswegen dekor ist einfach ein paar
gesichter und ich mach das jetzt auch
mit schokoladen also mit modell ihr
schokolade mit deko job und zeit mich
jetzt einfach wieder zu
muss
ich habe ziel bisher was vorbereitet und
zwar habe ich jetzt diese weisen kreise
ausgestochen dann die silbernen ring
außenrum die habe ich mit ganz normaler
kristall pulver farbe in silber abgebaut
und jetzt habe ich hier diese streifen
in spaß und die streifen in schwarz
kommen jetzt auf jeden muffin drauf denn
das ist diese dritteln halterung und
deswegen klebe ich jetzt einfach mit ein
bisschen wasser drang könnt ihr euch
einen pinsel und hier einfach so viel
anders machen dann schneide ich mir den
streifen so ungefähr zurecht
mit ihm darüber jetzt könnte das mit dem
werkzeug eben schön hin modellieren
m
nicht
so sehen jetzt die fertigen minions aus
und ihr könnt sie gerne auch im
kühlschrank aufbewahren also da passiert
nichts vor allem passiert auch dieser
modelle schokolade nichts die ist total
super ist auf same geeignet als mal ganz
auf seine drauflegen und eben auch die
linien schön oder die dekorierten sache
im kühlschrank stellen und wenn ihr
diese prozent nach machen wollt geht
einfach auf zeit.de
da gibt es noch mal die genauen zutaten
und die genaue anleitung auf jeden fall
ihr könnt einer schon diesen drei dingen
von 3 und diese tasche hier
da steht kevin drauf die vista oder
gewiss kein name ist die diagnose murat
ist halt einer von den minions und die
haben alle drei namen gibt das heißt ihr
müsst jetzt einfach die drei alle drei
nahmen auch allen tag genau zu
unterschreiben unterschreiben ich bin
ein bisschen aufgeregt und dann könnt
ihr diese tasche hier gewinnen und diese
drei reihen jetzt wo ich gerade
umgeworfen habe genau und das ganze
machen wir per losverfahren und es wird
dann einfach morgen auf facebook bekannt
gegeben und wir drücken euch natürlich
ganz arg die daumen und die samira will
sich glaube ich gar nicht von dieser
tasche trennen aber leider müssen wir ja
auf jeden fall hat es ist ganz viel spaß
gemacht und sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder
profis ohne brille zu tragen
nein
abonnieren
ja ja
mama